nous voici à thomson l'une des villes
les plus criminalisés au pays
cette bourgade du nord du manitoba
occupe le premier rang en matière
d'agression et d'homicide
il ya toujours quelque chose qui se
passe à chaque jour même toronto
montréal et vancouver se retrouve bien
loin derrière thomson
ça met beaucoup de pression c'est
peut-être un petit peu plus violent a
ici la seule différence c'est qu'ici en
ait moins de membres
vous avez combien de monde ici on a je
crois qu'on est rampante sur le plancher
au niveau de la ville
la plupart des interventions de la grc
se déroule au centre ville et personnes
qui ont posé ces crimes là ce sont en
état d'ébriété ou ont consommé de
l'alcool ou de la drogue
d'ailleurs la police fait régulièrement
des arrestations liées à l'alcool et la
drogue comme peut voir ici un monsieur
qui consomment leur consommation pour
endiguer ce flot de criminalité la grc
demande l'aide des organismes locaux
dont la fondation manitobaine de lutte
contre les dépendances et plusieurs
personnes souffrant d'une dépendance ce
jour nos centres de traitement
résidentiel de l'organisme
les participants suivent d'un horaire
établi par les organisateurs
varian des activités sociales aux soins
médicaux mercredi à mini grâce
escaudain user abuse
mais ce programme se termine après 28
jours alors que se passe t'il une fois
que c'est compliqué en d'autres mots les
toxicomanes et alcooliques sont livrés à
eux mêmes après un mois d'essai les mots
suivants une opinion partagée par la
député fédéral de la région
niki ashton ya des organismes et des
services dans la communauté absolument
essentiel ici à 35 par exemple mais il
n'y en a pas assez
il faut il faut pouvoir offrir plus de
services
les services à court terme des services
à l'antenne avant 9 heures
clean surtout président de thomson
raconte ne pas avoir reçu l'aide dont
ils avaient besoin
c'est à l'âge de 11 ans que sa
dépendance aux drogues commencé le match
du stade
bill clinton est sorti seul par une
prise de conscience lorsque son frère
toxicomane a failli mourir
toutefois il ne croit pas qu'il est si
facile aujourd'hui de se libérer de la
drogue et de l'alcool
surtout pour les jeunes de thomson il
reste de l'espoir des initiatives
locales font leur apparition au sein de
la communauté avec peu d'argent
elles veulent empêcher que d'autres
jeunes deviennent dépendants vous voyez
les jeunes de sos houston frings porte
c'est une équipe d'intervention formé
d'étudiants et de membres du personnel
de l'école secondaire de thomson
l'objectif de sos est de protéger la
santé mentale des jeunes qui étaient la
source des problèmes de dépendance selon
les organisateurs outre alloué
c'est en rehaussant l'estiment personnel
de ces jeunes que l'organisme espère
leur éviter de tomber dans les pièges de
la dépendance ici samuel rancourt
radio-canada à thomson heures
[Musique]